[Musique]
c'est le cas arriver le visage est
crispé que je me présente ici devant
vous
un soir d'août 2010 mentant dans la nuit
une clameur réveil le quartier ou
rousseau à gaoua un jeune homme aurait
tenté de cambrioler un commerçant
découvert il est tout de suite pris en
chasse par des riverains la foule
haineuse se déchaîne l homme est battu à
mort
chose très surprenante au lever du jour
son corps gît toujours sur la chaussée
et ce sous les regards d'un différente
des populations
pourquoi un acte aussi ignoble c'est
tout simplement parce que l'équité
étatique de notre pays est tellement
devenu fébrile à intel bois où l'on
préfère maintenant faire aux justices de
nous mêmes
comment sommes-nous à rival de telles
extrémités et pourquoi et bien charmante
auditoire c'est ce que arnaud togo
propriétaire d'un cybercafé nous
explique dans jeune afrique
et nous fait clairement comprendre que
si on livre ces criminelles à la police
elle remettra très vite on liberté et
même s'ils sont pris en flagrant délit
et sont tout de même libéré sous
prétexte qu'il n'y a pas assez de
charges pour ouvrir un procès
l'acte ainsi posé par ces arrivera n'est
autre que
la justice populaire
elle est la conséquence de la perte de
confiance des populations
vis-à-vis du système judiciaire c'est
ainsi résulte dans la colère de ces
derniers qui désirent combler les
manquements de ce système et par la même
occasion
protéger les citoyens de ces jeunes
malfrats qui ont fait des délits leurs
différents métiers de prédilection
quelles en sont les causes breton
s'inquiéter de ses conséquences oui mais
alors quelle solution peut-on envisager
pour mettre un terme à ce fléau
la justice populaire encore appelée
vindicte populaire est simultané
roland pourtant affirme à cet effet
qu'il ya une justice naturelle qui finit
toujours par ressurgir un bon sens
populaire qui prend le dessus sur tout
les médiocrités sur toutes les
déformations du coeur de l'homme
autrement dit le besoin naturel de
justice rendue que nous ressentons tous
est dû à toutes les injustices
auxquelles nous faisons face dans notre
quotidien dans notre société
le bon sens populaire et expéditif c'est
à dire immédiat et sans appel
l'ascension suis directement la faute
avec cette justice on n'a pas besoin de
se tracasser avec un procès ni avec tout
ce que cela comporte on a juste besoin
de vous attraper la main dans le sac
vous n'avez pas le temps de vous
justifiez vous n'avez pas le temps de
donner des explications
on ne se pose pas la question de savoir
si vous êtes coupable ou innocente
tout ce qu'on fera on se saisira de vous
en vous battra on vous mettra à terre en
voulait y sera avec de lourdes lattes
avec des pierres je ne sais quoi d'autre
et pour finir on va vous immobilisez
avec des pneus
mais à cet instant précis vous saurez
qui ne vous manquera que deux étapes
cruciales
votre baptême
non pas avec de l'eau avec de l'essence
avec du gasoil avec du pétrole au pied
avec de l'alcool
et en vous confirmera non pas avec de
l'huile sainte sur le fond mais avec une
simple bûcher d'allumettes enflammé qui
finira son voyage sur vous les saints
c'est jaillir plusieurs flammes qui vous
embrasures en
elle là votre existence ne sera pas
parti en feu ni en fumée comme on le dit
très souvent mais elle sera calciné
calcinés sous les regards sont rangés
sous les injures profanée par vos
bourreaux qui après cet acte sans
n'iront comme ça comme si de rien
n'était pourtant ils viennent quand même
doté ils viennent d'enlever il vient de
massacrer et vient de consumer une vie
ça paraît bizarre
ça paraît une solide mais pour eux c'est
légitime oui tu es quelqu'un est
maintenant devenu légitime rendre
justice
ils font preuve de tellement de
sauvagerie de mépris et de cruauté mais
ce n'est pas leur faute parce que c'est
déjà ancré en eux comme un processus
spontanée
l'impartialité commune est une pratique
très courante ici en afrique
elle a fait des plus longtemps du mot
justice une expression
déplorable cette probité vulgaire
est une notion sur laquelle beaucoup
d'auteurs ne s'attarde pas très souvent
mais pourtant être très couru être
récurrente est très répandue dans nos
sociétés africaines
c'est un droit qui ne s'intéressent
qu'aux aux histoires farfelues sur les
infidélités on a déjà vu sur les
trahisons parfois sordides sur le
tribalisme sur la corruption plutôt qu'à
ceux qui minent véritablement notre
continent et réduit considérablement
sa population
cet acte inhumain que certaines
personnes posent régulièrement
nous déshumanise
il est certes bien vrai que par de
telles manoeuvres les populations
expriment leur irritation mais toujours
est il que dans un pays de foix de loi
est de droit comme le nôtre de tels
actes sont hautement répréhensible car
nul n'a le droit de faire justice de
lui-même et par conséquent cela laisse
jaillir un grand nombre de ses caisses
la conséquence la plus néfaste comme moi
je déplore
c'est le mauvais exemple comment trop
tout petit
car on le sait tous nos petits frères
ont tendance à imiter à reproduire à
copier ce que font les adultes et les
aînés
peu importe si ce que vous faites et
bien pas ce n'est pas leur problème e il
transcrit seulement alors dites-moi
voulez vous leur laisser un héritage
plein de haine de rancune et de rancoeur
voulez-vous la reléguer un patrimoine
qui ne sait et qui ne saura rien faire
d'autre que condamner condamné est
toujours condamné sans toutefois pas
redonner
la balle est dans votre camp j'attends
de voir l'héritage que vous voulez me
laisser
la justice populaire est interdite
le code de procédure pénale qui est non
seulement extrêmement important et
innovateur précise bien dans un article
30 alinéa 4
il est écrit qu'aucune atteinte ne doit
être portée à l'intégrité physique ou
morale de la personne appréhendée que ce
soit par un officier de police
10 hier que ce soit par entre quelconque
particulier dans le cas du flagrant
délit ou la foule se met à poursuivre un
individu
cet interdit cette pratique elle est
interdite et même nos textes de loi le
stipule
mais est-ce que nous respectons
réellement les lois qu'on nous donne
c'est de ça qu'il s'agit
vous savez chers auditoire
si aujourd'hui j'ai voulu vous parler de
ce fléau qui accable le monde et qui me
dégoûte vous allez excusez mon propos
c'est tout simplement parce que
j'ai connu des personnes
qui en ont souffert qu'ils ont été
victimes
principalement un de mes amis
contrairement aux autres lui il n'avait
pas volé il n'avait pas a juré il avait
battu personne mais vous savez ce qu'il
avait fait
faux bon à savoir on n'était pas là
il a simplement voulu défendre sa petite
soeur qui avait été humilié en public
mais il a eu la malchance de tomber sur
les petits fois qu'ils sont un peu trop
cajolé par les grands frères là ceux qui
savent que lorsqu'on fait quelque chose
on n'a pas besoin de savoir si je suis
coupable pas je sais qu'après mon grand
père viendra
gérer le retour
on s'attarde dessus et pour nous les
faibles qui n'avons pas de grand frère
en fait comment on appelle nos aïeux nos
ancêtres où j'irai le retour on peut le
faire
quelques gris-gris et puis le tour est
joué
comprenez avec moi chez auditoire qui ne
suffit pas de grand chose pour être
victime de la justice populaire
une seule fausse accusation lancée à
votre égard vos condamne peu importe que
vous soyez innocente ou coupable non
s'en fout tout ce qu'on veut c'est à
vous battre battre vous battre vous tuer
vous avez aussi métier ça on sait même
pas si vous allez être enterré
normalement c'est pas notre problème
tout ce qu'on veut c'est rendre justice
rendre justice comment de la pire des
manières même la bible condamne cette
pratique
parmi les dix commandements de dieu il
est formellement stipulé que tu ne
tueras point
c'est vrai en avoir personne volet on
n'envoie personne agressée on a voit
personne comme être en tort ni au
forfait
mais vous là qui vous envoient leurs
coûts les condamnés qui
vous êtes devenus des prophètes vous
devenus des prêtres est-ce que vos
prophétisé en tuant ces gens
je me pose bien la question
si l'un d'entre vous n'a jamais empêché
qu'ils achètent et qu'il continue à
agiter cette pierre
pour tuer
et je me pose continuellement la
question de savoir s'il s'avère qu'un
jour
s'il s'avère même que depuis le
commencement de cette justice lorsqu'on
commet une faute envers la société et
envers dieu notre seul châtiment est de
passer par la justice populaire
combien d'entre vous seraient encore en
vie parce que quand je parle de
commettre une faute
même le plus petit péché que tu as
commis peut être condamné
j'ai voulu percer l'abcès j'ai voulu
prendre les choses
nommé demain c'est vrai qu'elles sont
petites mais elle contient tout ce que
j'ai à vous dire tout ce que j'ai à vous
transmettre
je suis aujourd'hui la voix de ces
personnes là qui sont partis à cause de
cet acte je ne sais pas une revenant de
rassurez vous
mais je veux par là vous faire
comprendre
que nous sommes tous des pécheurs nous
commettons tous des fautes alors
pourquoi juger pourquoi condamner une
personne qui ne fait même pas le tiers
de ce que toi tu fais
qui fait le mini parce que toi tu fais
parfois ce qui est pire mais personne ne
te condamne et voilà le caractère
ironique de la justice populaire
même les plus grands bandits ventes de
tuer
pourtant après ils feront pire que toi
mais dites-moi
entre les deux crimes lequel est le plus
odieux
lequel est le plus cruel lequel est le
plus ignoble
volet agresser ou bien tu es
répondez vous même à cette question
c'est un devoir de réflexion allait le
faire à la maison pas ici
je vous en prie
j'ai voulu parler aujourd'hui de la
justice populaire
parce que je crois en nos compétences je
crois en nos potentiels je crois à cet
avenir radieux en voudra construire
pour les futures générations
la violence est due à notre ignorance
et pour combattre cette ignorance il
faudrait avoir accès à l'éducation
cher auditoire
chers frères chers compatriotes
si aujourd'hui j'ai la chance de vous
parler des tedx c'est parce que ça a été
également mon rêve comme mes
prédécesseurs ici mais contrairement à
eux moi je n'ai pas rencontré il ya de
cela quelques années je les rencontre il
ya de cela quelques mois
j'ai dit je veux participer
à cet événement mais quoi dire c'est pas
facile de s'asseoir et de chercher un
sujet qui va captiver les gens je
pouvais bien venu me placer si vous
faire rire au lieu de cela je suis venu
vous sensibiliser mais si vous voulez
apprendre à rire d'ailleurs pour là
je suis en train de vous donner
juste le nécessaire
un nouveau code de vie qui permettra à
chacun d'entre vous de ne plus être un
partisan de cette terrible justice
je ne suis pas dieu je le sais
dieu seul pourra vous jugez pourra nous
juger
mais une chose est sûre c'est ravi et
fier que je vais quitter ce podium
parce que je vous aurais dit
ce que j'avais à vous dire
et comme on le dit très souvent en bon
entendeur salut merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]